for heaven's sake Heath stop that
infernal racket tell me what's up
must be something extraordinary to
provoke you to such musical lengths this
infernal racket that you so delicately
put at Rollins happens to be one of
humans famous melodies I think I played
rather well and something important has
turned up
I knew it that's all dear all at the
piano only confirm my suspicions what is
it this time something exciting one of
the most incredible cases I've ever been
called in on good good mystery I hope
mystery it is and unbelievable
wonderful wonderful
unbelievable mystery well come on let's
have it I received a message from
inspector Thorndike yesterday and I
dropped in to see him
the inspector seemed a little bit upset
he had every reason to be as I learned
later well what's up inspector ready I'm
going nuts
the inevitable ending to one on our
profession what is speeding the day well
I suppose you read the death of Senator
Bentley yesterday yes I did a great loss
to the nation mentally had more common
sense than any man in Congress you know
we're going to miss him very very sudden
wasn't it very I haven't the least bit
of evidence but I believe that Lee was
murdered on what do you base your belief
there was the imprint of an exon as far
and you and further that was the
signature of the murderer
I know it is Keith one of the greatest
killers in the world is loose in New
York 15 men and women found dead
yesterday and on the forehead of every
one of them that was scrawled in action
and yet no evidence of murder
none yes yes
217 Senate I'll be right over
they just got major collins of the
interceptor command jim collins sir why
he and i had lunch together the club
yesterday enemy x is killing the kind of
people we can't afford to lose
Jim was quite dead
stricken by some unseen enemy but I say
things like this just don't happen
unfortunately Rollins they are happening
and then every part of this nation over
400 people fell victim to enemy X
yesterday there were 400 died the day
before there will be 400 today 400
tomorrow but that's unbelievable it's
the bitter truth
at this rate 155 thousand men and women
of the United States are doomed by enemy
X to die this year men and women all
walks of life the poor the rich the fame
the unknown even new Valen may be on the
list so may I
but what can we do what can we do
gentlemen I'd like you to meet dr.
Crandell one of New York's most eminent
surgeons dr. Crandall mr. dorsen mr.
Heric are you well I enjoyed your scenes
in our proposed motion picture should be
very convincing well I only hope that
gives the same joke to our audience that
it gave to me you know doctor I find it
hard to believe that 400 of our people
die every day Kent so the tragedy of it
is mr. Harrigan that so many of these
people die needlessly if the disease
were discovered in time they could be
cured you mean if they go to their
doctor in time I mean they should go to
a competent physician at least once a
year and have a complete physical
examination in no other way can this
danger be averted
of course victims of cancer not stricken
suddenly as our mystery picture might
indicate oh no mr. Dudley I'm quite sure
that everyone knows that cancer is a
long and drawn-out disease the
technique used in the picture is what
one might tell me when a theatrical
license to emphasize our point as is
also the sinister sign of the ex each
serves to to illustrate the treachery of
this public enemy known as cancer but
there the allegory ends and make no
mistake about the point of the lesson
just as surely as if they were slain by
an unseen enemy one hundred and fifty
five thousand of our people will be
killed by cancer this year as you say
doctor many of these could be saved it
seems to me our job is to awaken them to
their danger you're exactly right mr.
Dudley this is a struggle of life and
death and we cannot win if we're afraid
or if we're ignorant of our enemy's
method of attack neither can we win by
complacency we've got to joke the people
into action you mentioned fear dr.
Crandall you mean that men and women are
afraid to go for an examination I wish I
could tell you of the hundreds of
instances that have come to my attention
men and women who came to see me but
came too late because they were afraid
or as in the case of so many women a
sense of false modesty kept them away
they make false modesty and a lie of
death let me get this straight doctor if
a man or woman feels in good health
should they still have a physical
examination
well it's precisely those people we want
to reach until certain symptoms appear
no one is aware that cancer has begun to
be certain and remember this is your
life you must have a complete physical
examination once a year there are so
many questions I would like to ask up
there questions I'm sure that everybody
would like to ask you they had the
opportunity well we wish everyone would
ask questions mr. Harrigan cancer is not
something to be spoken of in whispers
there should be open debate public
discussions such as recently took place
in one of our major networks
but it's very important that these
serious diseases should be brought out
into the open
in fact we ought to talk about things
like cancer we ought to talk about it we
ought to organize knowledge about it
it's important that it be talked about
it's necessary for the state of the
nation you're quite right mr. Bryson
everything concerning cancer should have
the widest possible publicity because
only in that way can the citizens of all
the Americas obtained the knowledge
necessary to fight this enemy you're in
the position to know dr. little look
you're managing director of the American
Society for the control of cancer is
there real progress being made very
definitely mr. Bryson the people of the
United States and of the Latin America's
are coming to be more and more
interested in the problem of cancer
control they realized that cancer isn't
a hopeless disease but that it's curable
that in fact is being cured when
discovered and treated in time if I
might add to that
yes dr. Binkley an equally encouraging
factor in our fight to control cancer is
whereas 10 years ago we had only a few
clinics serving our people today there
are nearly 400 qualified clinics serving
our people the research laboratories
have kept pace added to which is the
really magnificent work of the women's
field army the women's field army sounds
like a fine enterprise mrs. Olech your
national commander of it can you tell us
something about it
well the women's field army mr. Bryson
is a voluntary group banded together to
fight cancer each of our 200,000 members
and we wish that we might make it a
million pays a dollar a year as a
membership fee and pledges to work for
the control of Kent well mrs. Ellie
you've got 200,000 women enrolled for a
fight for cancer control what is it that
these women really
to within the limitation of our funds
which are hardly adequate for the
purpose we endeavor to keep the message
of cancer control constantly before our
respective communities thus we do by
serving as an Information Center by
seeing to it that no one is without
proper medical treatment and by
everlastingly pounding away at the
necessity of everyone having a complete
physical examination yearly mrs. ellic I
hope that in every community where your
army is not already established some
public spirited women can be found who
will do their what's being so splendid
they've done where you are underway this
has been very interesting and of course
it's much more than interesting it's
extremely important I'm sure that
everyone feels that it's an
encouragement to know that we have the
scientific ways now of controlling
cancer there are so many questions come
to mind dr. Crandall but first and most
important what are these symptoms how
will we know there are certain
indications mr. Harrigan that we must
lock in our mind and forever remember if
you have a persistent lump or thickening
especially of the breast see your doctor
at once
watch for any irregular bleeding or
discharge from any of the body openings
a sore that does not heal especially
about the mouth or lips or tongue is a
danger signal look out for any sudden
changes in the form or rate of a mole of
wort and finally be wary of persistent
in digestion especially when accompanied
by loss of weight however I must
emphasize that these symptoms are not
positive proof of cancer but don't
decide that for yourself you must be
guided by your physician
Thank You dr. Crandell I feel better
about this now that I have a little
knowledge of what to expect and what to
do and everyone will feel better mr.
Dorsey once the fear of cancer is
removed and the whole program is brought
out into the light of understanding I
want to thank you too doctor and I hope
our little contribution helps in the
fight well I'm sure it will mr. Harrigan
this is a fight in which we must all
engage this is war and we must face the
enemy with courage we are making
progress we are saving lives that might
have been lost we have every reason to
face the future cheer and hope and
confidence